did you ever um uh come to be acquainted
with the Reverend Eevee Hill I know
Eevee Hill very well yeah and what he
did in downtown Los Angeles Church of
the open door was very interesting and
I'm sure you know this but I'll say it
for the audience Reverend Eevee Hill
pointed out that every young man
regardless of race needs love discipline
and respect starting at age 11 to 18 for
them to mature as young boys to Here
Come the hormones and to truly mature
into young men and he warned that in his
analysis of the terrible what was going
on in his backyard and for people don't
know Eevee Hill churchy open door it's
down there just blocks away from USC
this great pillar of learning and South
Central Los Angeles which has got all
the reputations with the Crips and
bloods went on and he pointed out that
the gangs perfectly filled the hole that
a
fatherless um home does with love
discipline and respect cuz in the gang I
will love you and kill for you and I
will defend you with my own life
discipline you will not break our laws
or rules or you will be killed and then
respect comes from negative
accomplishments here you go you got to
cap one of the other gang members today
so that we can show that you're a man
and you're part of us and love
discipline and respect is needed by
young men 11 to 18 and the gangs
perfectly filled the hole and what
you're talking about the hole in the
heart and what the Woodson Center is
doing it almost sounds like the um
sermon I heard that there's a God shaped
hole in the heart of every man every
person and that you're trying to fill
that and and we have people who we have
models around the country of young men
and women who have stepped up and are
being and we can measure we can tell you
680 kids from one public housing project
one of the worst in the country went on
to college we have a an institution
pineywood Day School uh it's a boarding
schol school that was started 115 years
ago in in Jackson Mississippi they pull
from the same demographic as a Baltimore
School 96% of the kids come there go on
to college or post-secondary education
when they're from the same demographic
as the ones who are failing in the in
the public school system so we have
models of moral and spiritual Excellence
that builds on the same values the
challenge is how do we resource them and
and take them and and make them the the
centerpiece for instance the the whole
song Rich Man north of Richmond by
Oliver Anthony
50 uh uh million people responded most
of them black to his
message when you go go on internet you
will see that a lot of the black DJs to
speak to that population in the black
community resonated with his message yes
he's very popular why do you think
because I think there is a quest a deep
thirst for virtue there's a deep thirst
to return to the values that sustained
us from the beginning but we we don't
have a vehicle for that for that desire
to get expressed and that's what we're
trying to do at the Woodson Center is to
say to people uh the the
millions the the the the guilty white
people who put a 100 million into to to
Black lives matter and then put 50
million into this Center at Boston
University Abraham Ki uh studying
anti-ra racism how could they raise $50
million in in in a year to study racism
and and guilty white corporations give a
100 million to Black lives matter this
and both of those institutions are
frauds why can't we invest that kind of
money into institutions within the
Community like voices of black mothers
are united like pineywood day school so
what we're trying to do to say if you
get more of what you reward and less of
what you punish so we really need the
shift of the focus of our
investments in
institutions that speak to the uh uh
founding values of the country so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here